[Music]
please join me in welcoming namita nanda
kumar
[Applause]
all right thanks everyone it's exciting
to be here um
so danny was a great lead into this
because he works in hockey and was
talking about football
and i work in football and i'm going to
talk about hockey
just to give you a bit of background i'm
a quantitative analyst with philadelphia
eagles
but i also have done a lot of public
hockey research in the past
to be honest a lot of my public research
is like
really niche stuff about the draft that
frankly none of you need to hear
right now so i thought that it would be
maybe more interesting
to learn about one of the most popular
stats in public hockey analytics today
so that's expected goals which is why
the title is finding expected and
unexpected goals with r
just to give you guys a bit of
background there might not be some
sports anal
some sports fans in here uh but this
this definition worked really well the
last time i used it at a technical
conference so i'm going to keep with it
violent soccer on ice and
there are 31 soon to be 32 as danny
knows teams in the nhl
who spend all year trying to be good
enough at violent soccer on ice
that they win the stanley cup um why
does it matter
um i don't know some people think it's
fun there are
literally dozens of us who love it so
that's really the motivation here
uh and and so we can start to think
about what are some ways to evaluate
hockey teams and players
uh maybe the most obvious one is the
number
the percentage of times that they win
hockey games that seems relevant
but also in order to win games you need
to score more goals than your opponent
so goals four goals against also seems
valid uh
in order to score a goal uh you need to
take a shot
what's that saying you miss 100 of the
shots you don't take so
you can look at shots for and shots
against
you'd also just rely on your personal
feelings i think that that is
equally valid so i just wanted to put
that up there but since we are at
an r conference let's talk about the
statistical aspect
so shots four and shots against have
this really nice
uh property for analytical purposes of
being one of the most granular things we
can observe you know if there are five
six seven goals in a game uh you know
there are dozens of shots
that we can look at uh but the natural
retort to this
uh which has been true for for years as
long as
people have evaluated shot based metrics
uh is that not all shots are equally
dangerous
and that's right they're right to
criticize that um
and so that begs the question what are
the other features that we can account
for
in hockey analytics and so let's take a
look
so i wanted to give you guys a little
visual here so this is a
goal um that happened recently
uh again we're starting from the basics
here um
and to give you a little bit of a closer
look at this goal uh you know again this
is a randomly chosen
it's not really random um i'm from
philly i'm a flyers fan so it's
supplier's goal
um from this season so it happened a
couple weeks ago
um and uh it's worth
uh trying to figure out you know what
can we say and what can't we say
about this goal so
just by looking at the play-by-play data
we know that it was in fact a goal
it was scored by flowers forward travis
knechney on king's goalie jack campbell
it was at even strength so there were
five skaters on the ice for each team it
wasn't like a penalty situation or
anything weird like that
um it was right in front of the net
about 18 feet away
it was a wrist shot and it caused the
flyers to go up two nothing
and in particular with this labeled shot
location you know i have a little
orange dot right where the trackers say
uh the shot was
but what is the play-by-play data hiding
and it's worth knowing
you know what are the strengths and
limitations of our data so first of all
actually you know it's really nice that
they labeled the shot for us
but frankly the angle looks a bit off
which is definitely plausible because
these shots are manually tracked
i say for now because the nhl has
promised that they're going to implement
tracking data this year
which will probably affect that
but for now we can assume there is
recording bias
to some extent with these shot locations
so
if we look back at this kind of looking
at where travis connecting is
um i probably would have labeled the
shot a little bit to the right so we can
say
you know the distance maybe looks pretty
pretty good but the angle is a bit off
so if we're making any models uh with
that data that's something to keep in
mind
um it's also worth noting that before
the goal happened
connecting was set up with a great quick
pass that he was able to handle right
away
um if the pass wasn't as good he might
not have gotten as good of a shot off
he was also wide open there wasn't any
defenders in his like immediate vicinity
and there were two players uh screening
the net again we can see it
right here so that probably gave the
goalie some trouble
um so all of that is to say you know
there there's a lot of stuff we know
about the shot there's a lot of stuff
that we don't know
probably if we incorporate all of this
stuff that
we can't see in the play-by-play data
it's probably a more dangerous shot
than we would be able to estimate um but
you know
let's let's try it anyway see what we
can come up with
so unblock shots um
block shots are like if you shoot and i
stand in front of you and it hits me
and like i get hurt real bad but it
doesn't go near the net um
so unblock shots that actually make it
to to the net
um at 5v5 have scored about six percent
of the time this season
uh but i think tk travis connecting's
shot uh was better than that so how can
we quantify this
um and this is where you know i'm going
to introduce expected goals to all of
you and say that all of you can do this
right now
because it's worth contextualizing shots
with all this information that we have
um by turning them you know instead of
saying all of them are equal
we can start to estimate the probability
of scoring
uh for each shot and everyone with a
possible understanding of hockey
which i've just given to you right now
and are which i hope
uh a lot of you i think have come in uh
with that knowledge can build an
expected goals model right now
um by the opinion these are facts the
opinion is that this is a fun thing to
do so you'll just have to
take my word for it on that
and before i go any further it's
definitely worth noting that this is not
some idea that i came up with
expected goals has been a stat in the
hockey analytics community for quite a
while
and there have been a lot of really
smart researchers to take a crack at
this
um and all you know i can't go through
all of their
write-ups but if this is just to say
that none of the ideas that follow are
like brand new
or uniquely mine or anything like that
uh the
the stuff i do claim is my gg plot theme
and talking about my favorite players
that's all me
uh and so i was talking about the
play-by-play data
uh it's worth looking into you know what
are we
where are we finding that uh the short
answer is the nhl
the longer answer is that a lot of
people have put a lot of work into
scraping nhl data and cleaning it
one of these people is peter tanner from
moneypuck.com
so i give him a lot of credit for making
this data really easily available for
everyone
because he scrapes nhl data every single
day and shares
season-level csvs of every unblocked
shot and all of the
associated play-by-play information and
so for the purposes
of this talk we're going to use the
information from
2017 to present so like two and a half
seasons the most recent ones
and there is a lot of stuff that he did
for us that i didn't want to do
so thank you so much peter including
that he was labeled
shot types such as rush shots rebounds
etc
so for example um the play-by-play won't
say rebound
but you know that if the shot happened
within
two seconds of a previous shot that that
was probably a rebound
um he also adjusted xy coordinates for
recording bias
so i mentioned that these shot locations
are manually tracked
by you know a consistent group of people
at each arena so
the recording bias has some consistent
patterns
based on the arena that you're in so
there are adjustments for that
and in general cleaned it up
cross-referenced it make sure that it
was nice and ready
to be very tidally analyzed by us so
again
shout out to him um
this is the the big code chunk that i'm
sharing um it's not a complicated model
or anything but i really did want to
share this to show like this is
literally how easy it is
uh to get nhl shot data
on in your rstudio instance and
start to analyze it um and all i did
was write a function to download the
csvs on his website
uh and then use a bit of per um
to map that to the most uh three most
recent seasons
um and then i i love the janitor package
i love
clean underscore names um i love like
snake case i can't look at anything else
anymore
so there you go and i'll be tweeting
this out later so
i don't think you have to like write
this down right now or anything like
that
uh the first thing we can do before we
get back to expected goals
heat maps everyone loves heat maps so
there is also code available to
essentially make your own rank
in ggplot so i use that here
to make a heap map of just all the
unblocked shots
in this data and where they were
taken and you can see they're generally
taken closer to the net
i also made a heat map of the goals and
actually this alone can also tell you
that
you know shot location matters because
if it didn't matter if all shots were
created equal
these heat maps would look the same but
clearly you can see that shots closer to
the net are more dangerous which
also just makes sense like logically
uh the first thing we can do as kind of
a really lazy baseline thing
is just look at distance because i feel
like that's something that's really
important
and we can just use the logistic
regression um with polynomial term
and just estimate the probability of
scoring a goal based on the absolute
distance
to the net so the x-axis there is shot
distance
the y-axis is the the probability and we
can see that
just based on this one feature your
estimate can be anywhere
from near zero percent to near upwards
of 20 percent if you're really close to
the net
the slightly less lazy thing to do would
be to use something like xg boost
uh and also incorporate uh shot angle
shot type time and distance from the
last event
uh and also not assume linearity
we can do some cross validation to
choose the number of boosting rounds
um and i always feel like whenever i
talk about machine learning
i make it sound really simple and
unimpressive and i know you're not
supposed to do that
which is why i've incorporated these
images from google searches of machine
learning
of like big brains and like lots of
nodes and stuff
so like that is actually it it's not the
simple thing that i just said it's
you know imagine that
um and you know when we're talking about
variable inclusion it's worth uh really
thinking about it because frankly
you know we're not working with big data
hashtag big data here
um you know there's a uh not that many
shots even when you're
when you're going over multiple seasons
um and so
i i don't think this is the type of
problem that requires like a kitchen
sync approach of just like
tossing in all the variables and and
seeing what sticks um i think it's worth
it to kind of
uh rely on some domain knowledge as well
and think about you know what should be
important
things like shot distance shot angle and
what might not be as important
so i'm not including like score state
because i can't think of a reason why
after adjusting for everything else we
already know about a shot like the
distance angle
type etc i can't think of a compelling
reason why it would matter
that you took that shot if you were up
to or if you were down three or whatever
else
and fortunately this has also been
confirmed uh by previous expected
expected goals research um you know uh
researchers that have included
scorestate have found that it's like not
really that important
uh so it's good to hear that
confirmation
uh you could also include shooters and
goalies and i would say that it is
important to know
who is the goalie for the shot who is
the person who is shooting the puck
um but you know once you incorporate
them as variables
you have to make decisions about sort of
model structures and especially what
you're going to do
about players who have really small
samples you know if they've only shot
the puck
five times you know are we going to
regress them to the mean how are we
going to do that
etc so for the sake of simplicity i'm
going to evaluate shooters and goalies
by their
residuals in this model and limit it to
players with
enough of a sample size that we feel
comfortable evaluating them
and just really quick some variable
importance metrics from
the actual boost model uh we can see
shot distance is the most important one
by far uh and actually even the second
um most important is also
just a component of shot distance so
really that is what matters
uh which i think makes a lot of sense uh
the type of shot and like whether it was
a defender or forward
uh matters a lot less i think especially
the fact of like position not mattering
probably what's happening is that's
being incorporated
in the shot distance variables uh
because defenders tend to take shots
uh much further away from the net so
you're probably seeing that effect there
as well
um so i love uh fitting smooths
to again glance at calibration uh in
addition to looking at sort of standard
evaluation metrics so here i have three
models the logistic model
my xgboost model and also the money puck
data
includes peter tanner's expected goals
model as well so we can compare that
um and so the x axis is the fitted
expected goal value
uh the y-axis is um i mean
it's the indicator of whether it was
goal and then as we fit a smooth
it should be online y equals x if it's
really well calibrated
uh we can see that uh for the logistic
model you can barely see it
um because it's just kind of on y equals
x from zero to 25 percent basically
which is saying that like it's well
calibrated but you know obviously
limited in a lot of ways
it doesn't have information to call any
shots super dangerous
uh the xg boost model does a bit better
in that respect although some of the
really high
fitted values are
becoming goals like less than you'd
expect money puck
also strays a little bit once you get to
the really high values
but there honestly are much fewer shots
uh in those categories
uh some more model comparisons so you
know i always like to make the point
this is a a problem that has a lot of
class imbalance
um so i could i could stand here and
tell you like oh my accuracy is like
95 or whatever and that would sound so
good but all i did was just say that
no shot will ever become a goal um so
uh which you know goals goals do happen
sometimes so we
can look to things like log loss
and compare it to the situation where we
say all shots
are equally dangerous we can compare
that to our logistic model with the one
feature we can compare that to the
actual boost model
and here i'm using the the cross
validation predictions so
you know rest assured that these
predictions
have not looked at the
the data of that shot in question that
is being predicted
and also again the money puck model
which is a nice
benchmark for comparison as well and
you look at log loss you look at area
under the curve you can see that
basically
what it comes down to is just distance
alone
will get you most of the way there um
the
xgboost model with a few additional
features um
gets you a little bit further and then
probably you know whatever peter did for
his model
is was a little bit better but you know
i think it's great
uh that i was able to get close to his
results um
in frankly like a day of work so calling
that a win
um and then also to bring things full
circle
we looked at travis connecting his goal
earlier
and we knew that it wouldn't be right to
assume that it had the same probability
of scoring
as like the average shot
so that would be about 5.7 percent um if
we incorporate the shot distance
and look at the logistic model we would
assume about a 10
chance of scoring um the xg boost model
goes a little bit higher closer to 12
and then moneypox model i think does the
best job by saying it's 15
and then you know if we have additional
features maybe from tracking data or
something like that
uh we might even say that it's it's more
dangerous than that
um and lastly because i said expected
and unexpected goals
so here's what i mean by unexpected
goals so we can use this
to evaluate shooters and what we do
essentially
and i have some nice um tidy verse verbs
there
um we can uh for each shooter and all
the unblocked shots that they have in
this data set
we can calculate uh their expected
shooting percentage based on our
expected goals model
we can calculate their actual shooting
percentage based on the goals that they
scored
and the difference and then once we
filter down to
enough shots that we don't have really
wonky results
uh you know these are the the top six
for the time frame that i looked at
and so uh we can see brett connolly
logan couture
berkovsky burkhovsky dreissidel kopitar
paneran
these guys conditioning on where they
were shooting the angle etc
have scored at the highest you know
percentage relative to that
and so that is interesting from a player
evaluation standpoint
uh so with that that's all i have for
you guys thank you so much for listening
and thank you again to
money puck and some of my other friends
manny micah luke and josh and all the
other researchers
i've read and cited i'll be tweeting
this out at nnstats
so you can find me there and i'll take a
few questions if there's time
we do have time for one question um how
is the information communicated to the
coaches and players
uh are there analytics that can be
provided mid-game uh that leads to
strategy changes
um this is actually something that i'm
curious about myself and and frankly you
know i'll mention a little bit of my day
job here
uh because football is so discreet in
the plays
uh and stuff like that like there are
definitely materials that we can provide
saying like if you uh see this situation
this is what you should do
but frankly i'm curious about it myself
in a hockey context what are the sort of
adjustments
that you can make in-game uh frankly a
lot of the research that i've done has
been more on the
player evaluation side of things so just
trying to build up the best roster
and then kind of be like all right go do
your best
that's all the time we have
unfortunately thank you again
you